[Music]
president biden issued an aggressive
executive order to combat the
coronavirus here in the united states
all nine million federal and contract
workers must be vaccinated or face
losing their jobs private sector
companies with more than 100 employees
must require vaccinations or weakly
coveted testing and businesses that
don't comply will face fines
vaccinations will also be required for
the 17 million people who work at
hospitals that either receive medicare
or medicaid funding
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
well the president's goal is to get
shots in the arms of the nearly 80
million eligible americans who have not
yet received the coveted vaccine the
administration is also increasing
testing supplies and making those
at-home kits a bit cheaper and now with
the spiking cases among children and
teenagers the president is urging
schools to set up regular testing both
for staff and for students these new
sweeping new coveted mandates as you
might imagine raising eyebrows with some
local companies and workers
for me to go in and and make that call
and make that take away that personal
decision otherwise they're not going to
have employment anymore that's a tough
thing i'm afraid that this is going to
trigger something
with the employer and i end up getting
fired based on something that i cannot
control
president biden says companies could
face fines of 14 thousand dollars per
violation